hey gq i'm joe curie i play steve
harrington on stranger things and i'm
going to be breaking down his biggest
moments
[Music]
hey man
what's going on nicole here is uh
telling us about your work he's
overconfident full of himself thinks he
can kind of do whatever he wants and
he's chasing nancy pretty hard
i really like
only seriously i have to go
hey let's
let's do something tonight yeah i can't
i have to study for kaminsky he's kind
of met a girl that he couldn't get right
off the bat and it's intriguing to him
and she's different than a lot of the
other girls that maybe he's been with
are you crazy
my mom would not climb through your
window she won't even know i'm there i'm
stealthy i like a ninja what are you
doing here i told you on the phone i'm
under house rest now i figured we just
study here that was the first scene that
i filmed on the show
with natalya hopping through the window
and helping her study
this test so just bear with me
what'd i tell you
ninja
i was very nervous for that first day i
mostly remember preparing the scene with
natalya as well we kind of went through
it a bunch and had some ideas about it
was this your plan all along to
get in my room and then
get another notch you know
i'm not lori or amy or becky you mean
you're not a [ __ ]
that's not what i'm saying you know
you're so cute when you lie
shut up the main thing i remember is my
nerves mostly but once things started to
kind of click on set things were working
and the brothers seemed to be happy with
what was going on i was able to loosen
up a little bit but
yeah a long time ago feels like a long
time ago i don't know what you're
talking about oh no oh hey please give
me my back no
oh man he is like totally trembling you
must really have something to
hide here we go that was in episode two
or three
and that's the thing about perverts
it's hardwired into them you know they
just can't
help themselves i kind of had a hard
time sort of being mean to charlie
because i love charlie so much and he's
such a great friend oh wait wait hey
call me tommy
it's okay i think in the edit you can
notice actually i kind of
was not really aware of continuity so i
think i go to drop it like this or
something and then i actually end up
dropping it like that it's very hard to
watch and not remember exactly what was
going on the day and just watch as sort
of a regular viewer because you're just
remembering oh yeah i had to memorize
all these lines
that was the audition scene for the
character i just did a tape with my
friend matt williams going through it it
felt like i had like i kind of
understood what they were going for with
the john hughes references and so just
kind of tried to play into that skyped
with the brothers and then that was and
then got the part so thank god
[Applause]
that stuff is really fun because you
have to get into
it's kind of methodical and it's kind of
slow the way that it's all done um
but it's really enjoyable to
do something that's very physical on set
because it kind of takes you out of the
fact that there are you know people all
around so i i really like that stuff and
as the show has gone on i've gotten to
do more and more of it and what
you just wait until uh
until you feel it
feel like
it's like before it's gonna storm you
know
you can't see if you can feel it like
this uh
electricity you know like in the
electromagnetic field when the clouds in
the atmosphere no no no no no no no no
like like a like a sexual electricity
these first two episodes where kind of
me and nancy have this falling out and
her and jonathan go off and start to do
this thing and then i think they were
kind of like well there's not really
anything for steve to do he's kind of
you know at this point kind of not
really serving the story thankfully um
they kind of thought
it would be crazy and some sort of odd
couple moment to put me
with gayton who plays dustin it's pretty
random i mean we just intersect paths
going to i think the wheeler's house and
then kind of were you know spurred off
from there back into the story you kept
something you knew was probably
dangerous in order to impress a girl who
who you just met
all right that's grossly
oversimplifying things reading that was
really amazing and the brothers had told
me beforehand that i'd get to be um
working with him he's also just such an
incredible and talented kid well not
everyone can have your perfect hair it's
not about the hair man the key with
girls is just
just acting like you don't care
even if you do i mean even then when he
was very little it was just so clear
that he's a really gifted actor just
incredible to work with so i mean it was
just so fun and such a different
relationship than the steven nancy thing
i got to sort of play this big brother
role and kind of tap into something else
for stephen i think that ended up really
shaping the character as as things went
along
i mostly remember laying on the ground
for the coverage of him
cameras like right here just kind of
like getting like my
hair dirty in the frame i just remember
being so
terrified of taker because he was so you
know
he's you know he's a very uh very into
this character and he was very you know
he was giving it his all so you know
just scrapping
yeah you know a lot of adrenaline going
we'd never done anything like this it
was like the fight day you know had a
nice little
real bruise to go with my fake fake
bruises
now you're gonna go in there yeah look
like a million bucks yeah and you're
gonna slam dad like a lion
[Music]
yeah i don't do that okay when we
started they were i think nine to 12 12
maybe 13 at this point now filming
season four and they're full adults i
remember the like the other day gaitin
drove me home from work i'm pretty sure
that mom was trying to bang her son wait
wait the hot chick was out to be king's
mom yeah i'm pretty sure but they were
the same age no but he went back in time
then why is it called back to the future
he has to go back to the future because
he's in the past so the future is
actually the present which is his time
what i kind of liked where we
picked up uh steve at the beginning of
season three he's kind of at a low point
and he's lost and he doesn't really know
what he wants and i think that that's
really relatable especially when you're
leaving high school
to not really know what you want so i
really like that and i really also like
the intersection of stephen robin
because i think that again the brothers
paired steve with this really nice
character that brings out this other
side for him why they're so nice to me i
don't know tammy thompson
i wanted her to look at me
but she couldn't pull her eyes away from
you and you didn't even like her and
i would go home
and just scream into my pillow
tammy thompson's a girl
steve
yeah
oh
oh
we worked out a lot we worked that um
that scene a lot and shooting that scene
took took kind of a while but me and
maya were both aware that it was a
pretty pivotal scene i guess for both of
the characters it was really amazing
because seldom on this show do you have
the time to really have kind of these
emotional
moments or big chunks of dialogue also
there's a lot going on in this show so
to stop all of this
supernatural sci-fi action
to stop that train for like three pages
of dialogue i just remember it take
taking kind of a while to shoot which we
were both pretty happy about because of
all the different sizes and then also
because there were some pretty cool
moves camera wise in that like i'm
specifically the bird's eye when i go
under going to her stall great writing
for that scene
floor's disgusting
yeah well i already got a bunch of blood
and puke on my shirt so
[Music]
oh that was actually pretty brutal to be
honest but being tied together that was
really tough because you're on the page
you read it and it's like oh my gosh
it's gonna be so amazing to watch but
then you get there and you actually are
just tied up for like three days but
also when you're doing it you're like
you feel pretty in it i guess because
you're actually constrained and every
season they also give me
they really beat the [ __ ] out of steve
so i always feel like i have some crazy
makeup or like season one i had this
contact in season two i had all that
stuff up my nose and then season three i
had the big puffy eyes which is fun to
look at and probably less fun to be
be in
[Music]
they always give me a little fun hero
moment for steve they always give him
some cool thing everybody knows how
season three ends but it it plays really
well into the beginning of season four
it feels like his arc is really a
continuation
kind of starting as a kid and growing
more into a man or at least getting
there sorting out what you want out of
your life and the sort of people that
you want to be associated with and be
around i guess because that kind of says
a lot about you i think steve
finds those people you start monday
you start never
i'm really excited for this next to come
out in dead to be able to actually talk
about it